واسع صاحبه المسلسل التاريخي سفر برلك
الذي يحكي قصه التهجير واباده اهالي
المدينه المنوره عام
1914 على يد الدوله العثمانيه نجوم عرب
وسعوديون او سعوديون نعم شاركوا في
المسلسل الذي حقق مشاهدات عاليه خلال شهر
رمضان بعض ملامح المسلسل في هذا التقرير
[تصفيق]
الوجه الاخر للدوله العثمانيه في بلاد
العرب عنوان عريض لمسلسل سفر برلك الذي
وثق ويلات واحداثا تاريخيه عاشتها المدينه
المنوره على ايدي العثمانيين قبل اكثر من
قرن
[موسيقى]
المدينه الهادئه والوادعه لم تكن كذلك في
عام
1914 حيث قضى اهلها بين تهجير واباده
وثقها المسلسل وفق عمليه انتاج عربيه ضخمه
ارشادات واسعه لقاها مسلسل سفر برلك بين
المشاهدين العرب والسعوديين خصوصا لتوثيقه
حقبه دمويه تاريخيه غابت عنها عمليه
الانتاج الدرامي طوال عقود
لوحات شعريه غنائيه وظفت في العديد من
مشاهد المسلسل الذي حل ضمن اعلى الاعمال
الرمضانيه مشاهده عبر تطبيق شاهد
[موسيقى]
والعرس عمل رفع ذائقه المشاهد العربي
وتطلعاته لاعمال تاريخيه توثق الاحداث
بدون قيود
الممثل السعودي الدكتور مؤيد الثقفي مؤيد
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابع مبروك عليكم
نجاح المسلسل وكل الاصدقاء
الرائعه اللي شفناها
ومبروك عليك انت نجاحك في الدور العظيم
اللي قمت فيه يعني في ثنائي حلقاته كلمني
عن المسلسل هذا بالنسبه لمؤيد الثقفي يعني
حياك الله استاذ خالد شاكر لك الاستضافه
وانت استاذنا وعلمنا يعطيك العافيه اول
شيء المسلسل هذا للامانه هو ليس بالنسبه
لمؤيد ليس مجرد مسلسل انا اول ما عرض علي
اني اقوم بتجربه اداء لاترشح لهذا العمل
وكان في ذاك الوقت العمل تحت او بقياده
المخرج الراحل السوري رحمه الله عليه
الاستاذ حاتم علي كان كل فخر وشرف طبعا
اول ما قرات النص
بصراحه صدمت بهذه الحقبه التاريخيه اللي
انا انا كنت ما اعرف عنها كثير صدمت
بالتفاصيل اللي قراتها رجعت تبحث فيه في
مصادر تاريخيه كثير قعدت اقرا كثير
للامانه
صاعقه كبيره كانت لي كممثل وبالعكس اضاف
لهذا العمل قيمه لكل فنان في هذه الحياه
يعني له اعمال يجد قيمه فيها ويجد رساله
وجوديه لنفسه فيها فانا وجدت انه في قيمه
عاليه من خلال هذا العمل من خلال الفن ومن
خلال التمثيل اقدر
بتثبيت وقائع تاريخيه حقيقيه صارت
ومع المفارقات فين كنا وفين صرنا اليوم
ولله الحمد والمنه اللهم لك الحمد على
نعمه الامن والامان كم انواع عمل ملحمه
ملحمه تاريخي اتشرف اني كنت احد افراده
وبالنسبه لي هو عمل وطني يعني هو كان
العمل الاخير اللي كان من المفروض ان
يخرجوا حاتم علي الراحل رحمه الله ثم بعد
ذلك جاء مساعده اللي هو اعتقد هو اللي
استلم اخراج هذا الفيلم او عفوا المسلسل
المسلسل تحس انه متعوب عليه انتاجيا ومكلف
يعني مو مقصرين
المنتجين في في دعمو بشكل كبير لكن
دورك انت كيف تصف مؤيد يعني خاصه انه انا
اشوف كثير من الاصدقاء والتهاني وكثير من
يعني الاجلال لك على ما قدمت فيها المسلسل
شخصيه شخصيه عبد الرحمن صح
الشكر لك استاذ خالد على هذا الكلام
صراحه يعني الله يعطيك العافيه وشكرا
لجميع الناس اللي صراحه يعني قدرونه
وشاركونا بتعليقاتهم ومشاعرهم النبيله
والجميله في هذا العمل والله للامانه يعني
فعلا من اكثر الادوار واقربها الى قلبي هو
الدور رضوان في هذا العمل لانه رضوان كان
شخصيه بكل بساطه هي شخص عمره 18 19 سنه
رضوان
رضوان وفي عمر خمسه سنين شاف عمه يقتل على
يد العثمانيين بكل ظلم وبكل حقد وبكل جور
وبكل ما تعنيه الكلمه من مهانه فنشا على
هذه التروما او نشا على هذه الصدمه فكان
طول الوقت ما بين في صراع ما بين ما بين
خوفو على اهله وخوفه على الوضع نفس الوقت
الطفل الصغير هذاك ما هو راضي على الظلم
اللي صاير فالحمد لله اتمنى اني اكون وفقت
في تجسيد هذه الشخصيه والفضل لله ثم يعود
طبعا القائمين على هذا العمل المخرج
الاستاذ الليث حجه للاداره الكفه وصراحه
وخير الملف يعني صراحه للاستاذ حاتم يعطيه
العافيه كان توجيهاته مستمره معانا في
اللوكيشن فالممثل حتى وانبرز فما هو بمجرد
مثل ففريق العمل كله يعني يساعده في هذا
الشيء الحكايه نفسها حكايه هذا المسلسل
انا اعرف انه كمان تغير اسم المسلسل كان
اسم ثم تغير الى اسم سفر برلك لكن انت هل
في عوامل ساعدتك انه انت تنجح في تجسيد
الشخصيه بشكل
بهذا الشكل اللي شفناه يعني قراءات جديده
نصائح من من اشخاص معينين
والله طبعا
بلا شك المخرج يعني له الدور الكبير كان
معانا الاستاذ عروه العربي ايضا احد مدربي
التمثيل معانا في هذا العمل يعطيه العافيه
كل الشكر لهم لكن للامانه للامانه القضيه
الجوهريه استاذ خالد كان العمل ما هو مجرد
عمل بالنسبه لي مو بس لي انا لي ولجميع
زملائي الممثلين السعوديين اللي كنا لانه
نحن كنا نصور طبعا زي ما يقولوا او خلال
المواقع فكنا نحن المدينه المنوره ممثلين
المدينه المنوره على على صله قريبه من بعض
من الاستاذ محمد وغيرنا فكان العمل
بالنسبه لنا هو ما هو مجرد عمل ولا لا هو
قضيه وجوديه بالنسبه لنا كسعوديين نحن لا
يعني فعلا العم محمد المدينه المنوره فكان
دائما طول ما احنا في اللوكيشن طول ما
احنا في موقع التصوير نسمع دائما بيتكلم
على هذه الحدث ويتكلم على تفاصيل فيها
فكنا نتغذى كثيرا يعني المساله مساله حقبه
تبى تبينها انت كممثل وهذه فرصتك وفرصه
عمر بالنسبه لك انك تظهرها بالطريقه
الصحيحه بكل تفاصيلها بتلك المشاعر حتى
تتجلى الحقائق للناس مبروك عليكم نجاح
المسلسل يعطيكم العافيه وموفقين والله انا
سعيد استاذ خالد اني استضفتك وهذا شرف
كبير لي شكرا جزيلا
ممثل السعودي المعروف واحد نجوم مسلسل سفر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات